alireza congratulations uh good day for
you at the office this was in my opinion
in our opinion the key matchup between
you and nepo who was just having a
brilliant event after that point and we
got this position it felt like it's just
going to end in a draw but you are still
putting more and more pressure do you
feel like you have a good chances here
yeah no but of course if he keeps my
double points he's just draw um he he
miscalculated something after rook f2
yeah did just king h7 it's just
luke h5 king g6 rook d6 rook f6 here ah
to f6 you have to not
to put keep the double pawn and i don't
have realistic chances here you go here
eric f2
if you take with the pawn probably or
even worse at this point
and then luke takes king g6 okay i could
play this one this is just versus two
but the pawns are still doubled so yeah
it was okay he messed up something here
it still should be draw but yeah now i
have good chances because my i don't
have those points so
and uh yeah when did you feel he made
the final yeah uh i think
still okay i think maybe king e
ah brooke a3 is already a mistake
okay three yeah i should start with
czech of course
yeah
and then i made mistake okay five check
yeah king eight of course
should be winning
yeah
but but uh
the game is not over yet right yeah yeah
it's rookie five yeah it's very
important only move king to f4 and
replace them
but still i think it's drawn on king g8
after qf-17 g8
king e3
uh
doesn't look like draw anymore
i think it is draw here
let's say
okay no no he's six rook c5
no no rook c5
takes a7 look at five king e4 rook f6
okay my king is already
okay some game is just waiting for you
what is salt yeah maybe instead of rook
c5 just to keep maybe yeah because the
two versus one is draw i think
so this one's yes two versus one is
going to be a
computer is maybe over exaggerating here
because how do we exchange this pawn is
the question yeah let's say okay one how
could i break let's say
king f8 yeah check get the king in
okay let's say okay five
we couldn't see how to break here okay
we still have to
let's see okay one
let's get
a f7 king g8
yeah there's another clear path yeah
look c7 and king d5 that he says okay it
should be winning yeah
rook a5 kings c not okay five king e6
yeah yeah so you have to go king d rook
d1
yeah and then you just go
and then king goes to b8 yeah okay
some study like uh victory but still
very huge victory yeah of course king g8
was the mistake king e8 was true yeah so
we're seeing you all the time well
actually we're seeing other players
cooperating with
their teammates let's say
we haven't seen you with anybody how do
you analyze these positions when you get
those 10 minutes yeah i don't think it's
very important it's very complicated
i don't think even they sit for 40
minutes they cannot find the best moves
because
uh the chess that we are playing we are
unannouncing for thousand years it's not
even clear what to do
first move so
i think it's kind of just for fun they
are doing so but in general i like to be
i like to concentrate before the game so
but okay everybody has different
approach you're just like a quiet mental
space and
relax before the game it's a bit strange
for me because we are competitors
and they are talking together it's a bit
weird for me but okay maybe
it's not
very important for them this tournament
i don't know what is the case but is it
important for you is the big event for
you yeah in any tournament i play i'd
like to play my best so otherwise i
would not compete so
um yeah i think i played decent here but
until here but i'm very disappointed
with the last game so
but okay still it's fine there was a
miss but at the same time he also
pressured all the way until at the end
alireza always competitive always a
pleasure to see you play and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you
our congratulations as well ali reza me